strauss and giroux the story is set in
the late 1900s and chronicles the
travels of a polish-born actress in
america
miss sontag's talk recorded recently at
politics and pro's bookstore in
washington dc
lasts about an hour
well i
i want so many things i want to say
before i get to my book
uh first of all i want to thank the
person who gave me this
wonderful present um
the
my i'm i'm i am also speaking now in the
presence of of of my oldest uh my
earliest polish friend and my polish
translator will be especially amused by
that who's in
here tonight there is a candies called
majeskas
and some of you
may know
that there really was a
polish actress who gave up her career
at its pinnacle
she was 35 years old
she was the queen of the polish theater
and it's the year 1876
and with her husband and her
teenage son
and some friends who included
a young writer uh who went on to become
a very uh famous writer in fact an early
uh
uh
an early recipient of the nobel prize
henrikh sinkhevitz the author of
quovatus
this group of people um set out from
poland
which as many of you
know
did not exist as an independent country
from the late uh um
18th century until the end of the
first world war
and immigrated to america with the idea
of
founding what we would call a commune
a a farm
going to live in a farm just as
some
wonderful
writers from massachusetts 30 years some
30 years earlier
had
founded a farm called brook farm
in massachusetts that included
hawthorne and thoreau
of the idea that of founding what of
what is called
and i'm very skeptical of these terms a
utopian colony or commune
um
like all of these ventures of course it
failed although it's not
something either to smile about or feel
superior to it's kind of complicated
why this one failed why brook farm
failed
it's a very interesting tradition in the
united in the united states in
the 19th century there were such
communes
in massachusetts and pennsylvania in
ohio in
texas
uh very often they were done they were
created by immigrants
sometimes they were created by
old line
wasp americans as in the case of brook
farm in massachusetts
this particular group of polish
immigrants and they were not by the way
the first polish immigrants to found
such a colony there was an earlier one
in texas
in a town with a french name called la
reunion
that had been founded about 10 years
earlier anyway this group of people
ended up and now you can giggle and i
and i i won't look disapprovingly on a
little village in southern california
called anaheim
and anaheim was indeed it existed it was
had about 2 000 people they were they
were german first generation german
immigrants
who had been recruited by a vineyard
business that existed in nearby los
angeles which had about
ten thousand people
they were about the only two settlements
in
southern california
while san francisco and its environs had
about 400 000 people at this time so you
know
more than half of what it has now
and uh
northern california was quite settled
san francisco is a major city the
biggest city west of the mississippi in
fact the only city real city west of the
mississippi
uh whereas southern california was empty
in quotes you know the way the way white
colonists always say empty meaning
they weren't going to pay attention to
the native americans and the mexicans
and other people who were living there
um
anyway they went to
anaheim
uh where these uh german immigrants had
come 20 years earlier and founded this
uh
of this little village uh
which is sponsored by the by the company
in los angeles and there were vineyards
and they produced one undoubtedly lousy
wine
but it is kind of interesting that wine
wine
producing wine production
began in southern california in this
quote-unquote empty part of california
not in the north
uh where of course it eventually uh
took root uh metaphorically and
literally
and is now a major major activity in
northern california napa valley et
cetera there was but there was no uh
wine producing in the north in
california at this time only in the
south anyway they
they stayed there for a while i'm
talking about
well the real people now
uh a while no it's not true they
actually the actress stayed there three
months
and she bailed out and went to san
francisco for about a year
eight months a year uh studied english
got herself an audition
and went back on the stage and went on
to have an incredible career
now her name um as it was uh shortened
uh when she uh
reemerged on the american stage was
indeed majeska helena majesca so it was
i was very touched that somebody thought
to bring me these candies
called majescos now i don't quite
understand the
history of this they seem to be made in
kentucky
and as far as i uh know
the only the only association i have
with majeska that is to say the real
polish actress
uh and kentucky is that
in louisville kentucky
in 1883 uh to say about seven years
after majeska
after this polish actress went back on
stage in america and had a triumph and
became the queen of the american theater
polish accent and all
she attempted
uh
what she was known for was shakespeare
she was considered great shakespearean
actress and then she did a lot of
melodramas
uh and camille was was one uh adrian le
couvre was another one um
of plays that you really haven't heard
of i mean you've heard of those plays of
course because one is a film and one has
turned into an opera uh there was a play
called frou-frou which doesn't it's just
it's not as a uh
uh a comic story but on the on the
contrary a real weepy uh about a woman
who abandons her husband and child and
of course is horribly punished
and most famously of all
the most popular play of the 19th
century one of the most popular plays
ever written in terms of number of
performances a number of people who saw
it
a play called east lynn
which was done over and over and over
again thousands and thousands and
thousands of productions uphill and
downdale for
for decades into the 1920s
my own mother
uh saw east lynn in still done i guess
in the 1920s or something like that i
mean it was done let's say from the
1850s the 70 years of this play done in
every hamlet and village and town
in
the united kingdom
and in uh north america
uh however majeska the real actress uh
and i'll get to my novel in a minute is
uh is that the one with my sony
association with with um kentucky with
her is that she decided to bring
enlightenment uh to america and that she
would like to perform a play by this new
difficult controversial writer whose
name was henrik ibsen
and um she chose to
give the american premiere
of a play called doll's house
in louisville kentucky
thinking as i well i've sort of made at
this point i just got so inspired by all
this you can imagine what i did with
this in my novel
uh
well at the toward the end of her
preparation it seems that she chickened
out and she has nora know sort of go to
the door
and say well okay i'll give you another
chance
so it actually had a happy ending or a
quote unquote although you might say it
was an unhappy ending you know
she actually
you know at the end of the play it
appears to be willing to give the
unworthy husband another chance
um
even so it was an incredible flop
she never took it anywhere else because
they thought it was a very wicked play
that a woman should even consider
leaving her husband much less for the
stated reason in ibsen's play which if
you think about it it's pretty wild
stuff she's not leaving her husband just
because she's discovered that he is
really morally very defective person but
she says i have to find out who i am
that sounds very modern but in the 1880s
that was that was pretty wild stuff
anyway um
this story of the actress of the of the
polish actress who came to america was
something that i discovered entirely by
chance
which is the best way of discovering
anything
um browsing in a bookstore
in boston
in 1993
and i plucked down from the shelves of
a little
academic monograph which was a a study
of cincavitz of saint cavitz's writing
this this polish writer very popular
writer a writer that at least in
translation does not appear to us to
have anything other than historical
interest um but certainly covartis is
like east lynn as east lynn is one of
the best-selling best most most seen
plays of all time certainly
uh this novel quovatus is one of the uh
most read books of all time
and i in in this little tiny academic
monograph which is no more than a
hundred pages
i uh it says it was just really a couple
of paragraphs it said that saint kavitz
when he was very young had accompanied
this polish actress to
america
that they had gone to southern
california that it had been a failure
that she went back on stage and he went
back to poland and i thought oh that's
my next novel
now why how do you know these things who
knows but
thank you thank you
um you don't you just know i just i i
thought oh
with this story i can tell a lot of
stories i can tell a story about america
about discovering america i can tell a
story about i can write a theater novel
which is something i've always wanted to
do i'm very
interested in actors i love actors it's
a it's a
not always a happy love um
but i've spent a lot of time
part-time in the world of the theater
and films i know many actors many famous
actors
many famous directors i've sat in
countless directors rehearsals and been
on countless movie sets and
directed four films in europe myself and
directed a little in the theater and
written plays anyway i knew i could do
that i knew i knew enough to do that but
then i also wanted to tell
a story about america and i think this
the story of foreigners is always a
great story i mean the last novel i
wrote which is sort of beginning of a
whole new period for me as a writer
the volcano lover which came out in 1992
is also a story about foreign people uh
in in southern italy
um
and this is about polls in america
uh and the next one is going to be
in japan and it's also going to be about
foreigners
in japan in in the 1950s so
volcano lover is the late 18th century
this is
late 19th century
um
next one is going to be in the middle of
the 20th century and i don't know
i think i'll be caught up
uh
and uh
ready to try
just with no okay
um
i think i might be ready to to to assume
the uh inhibitions of the present
uh
because
i mean there's a whole story there too
which maybe i i i will save for the end
after i've read you a little from the
book
uh i didn't i didn't start uh by writing
um i did start by writing novels
contrary to what people think i didn't
start as an essayist i just fell into it
uh
and it i got kidnapped by it i was uh
fiction
was always my first love my first
book which i published in the 60s was a
novel then i wrote a few essays and they
got collected and wrote another novel
then i had some more essays and then i
kind of um
lost my way and lost some confidence and
in fact didn't write for a few years um
went off and made films went off and
lived in europe for seven years and made
films and did a lot of other things
uh and slowly sort of crawled back um
while writing
more essays notably
some essays on photography which i
thought would take six months and took
five years and
and a couple of uh essays on illness
crawled back i found my way back to
writing fiction and the real
breakthrough for me was
the idea of setting a story in the past
now that might sound like it's harder
and in some way it is of course
i mean you do have to work it up you
have to make sure you're not making some
idiotic mistake and you have to
understand
oh well you have to read a lot people
thought research i call it reading
you have to read a lot to make to sort
of know what people wore and what they
ate and what their furniture was like
and
and what it looked like when they went
out on the street and
you to to understand the material world
in which people live that's very
important to me i i feel that when i'm
writing i'm i'm behind the eyeballs of
my characters and i have to see what
they see
even if i don't put it down
uh i but i have to know a hundred times
more than i would ever actually put in
the book in the way of his little
historical details so there is a lot of
you know reading in the evening
and
you read diaries and you read newspaper
stuff and documents and letters and
history books and you look at art of the
period and you look at histories of
clothes and
and pictures and photographs and you
know you look at whatever whatever you
can look at and you kind of stuff your
head with with the the the thisness of
the world the thingness of that world
but of course the main thing
are your characters and the arc of the
story
um so as i said well there was a co a
certain amount of work you know as a
like a student would have to do to work
it up to work up the details of the
of the world so you don't make a mistake
in fact i found it was incredibly
liberating to set a story in the past i
just felt big gates opened up
in me i found an inner freedom and i
hadn't had before
i discovered that i was a storyteller
which i never knew i thought it was a
lot of things as a writer but i didn't
think i was a storyteller and i
discovered only when i started to set
fiction in the past that i was a
storyteller
so um
it does feels very much like a new
period and i i think
these two books um
the
volcano lover in america are by far the
best thing i've ever done they're very
different from what i've done before i
don't think they're historical novels
but they are novels that take place in
the past but they're not historical
novels in the kind of special sense like
mystery novels or science fiction novels
or something like that they are
stories that take place in the past and
i also think that you can't write about
the past without writing about the
present i mean since we are
hinged to the time in which we live
um
i uh
i don't know where to begin in this book
there's a part of me they'd like to just
read you the first 10 pages instead i
think i'll read from the end just
perversely
um
there
she goes back on the stage and it
becomes a theater novel and she
her dream is to play uh opposite
um um
edwin booth who is the great
actor of the period the the great
tragedian of the period and there's some
some
[Music]
context of different kinds of contacts
most of them indirect with booth from
the time uh
she comes to america i mean
right away
when they get to san francisco uh and
they're on the way to anaheim and she's
saying uh stage is finished for me i'm
not interested in anything anymore i'm
i'm going to be a farmer i'm going to
live the pure life and ride on horseback
under the blue sky and sleep on the
ground and all that of course she finds
out booth is playing in san francisco
and she immediately goes to see him
she i mean immediately it's a dream of
her life
to see him and she sees him
in julius caesar as marc anthony and she
sees him in merchant of venice as
[ __ ]
and
by the end of the novel she has she's
playing with booth and i want to
i give the last word in the novel to
booth
and i think i'd rather
that you think about him rather about
her because she's so complicated and so
interesting and i adore her i can't
i just can't
pick
exactly what i would want to do so i'll
give you booth instead whom i think of
as the unhappiest man in the world
this is late at night so it's done that
the book is written in a number of
different ways a lot of it is third
person but
at the beginning it's a monologue a kind
of arya
by
a sort of author figure who's sort of me
not really me but sort of me alter egome
and then at the end and then you've got
eight chapters
of
i'm sorry you get eight chapters of her
life and all these subplots and the
husband and the boyfriend and the child
and a lot of
subsidiary plots and
and characters
and then it ends with another monologue
those of you who who've read the volcano
lover will remember that that also
starts with a prologue that's in the
first person and ends with
four
women's voices women actually talking
from beyond the grave who are
characters in the story
so although the method of this book is
entirely different and uh
it's partly done through letters it's
diaries a lot most of it is in the third
person it this also ends with a
monologue and it is booth
talking to her and it's done like a like
a play like a play and it even has a
stage direction so
um i'll read you uh
just the beginning of the of the booth
monologue at the end
you see
my dear marina
i trust we may dispense with madame
marina and mr booth
now that we're alone and i'm exhausted
and sated with applause and quite as
drunk as i need to be
i must tell you that i didn't approve
when you came stage and touched me
tonight
keep your eyes fixed on me throughout
ignoring the others in the courtroom no
objection to that we both agree the
speech is addressed to [ __ ]
the quality of mercy is not strained it
droppeth as the gentle rain from heaven
no it doesn't but that's not the point
here which is my point my point is
porsche
is trying to convince [ __ ]
and thereby to move him
he's not easily moved
he has too many grievances
porsha may be moved herself by the
wretched fellow but porsha should never
touch
[ __ ]
even if she only touches his shoulder
touch his shoulder touch any other part
of him no touching
[ __ ] is in pain
stares into the glass he's holding and
being in pain
is very
combustible
looks up
i suppose you thought to show that
porsha is very feminine
under her red lawyer's robes very
feminine and therefore knows without
needing to behold it told that the ogre
has senses affections passions hurts
but that is a foolish sentimental
gesture
shakes his head
you are monstrously sentimental woman
has anyone ever told you that
i myself prefer
large
wrathful gestures
which does not mean
i shall not touch you before the evening
is over if i have a bit more to drink
don't tell me that you're married or
that you're no longer young or something
of that kind you're 13 years younger
than i am unless you lie about your age
as does every attractive woman who can
get away with it but let's leave that
the touching and the rest for later as
the whim strikes us
stands by the fireplace
for now
i shall only insist that you drink with
me
no
ladyish resistance excellent sign
excellent but nodding and smiling your
infallibly seductive smile and touching
the top of your lovely hair
aren't enough
i want to hear a robust
yes
edwin
yes
edwin
brava well done
finishes his glass and well done to you
ned
sets the empty glass on the mantle
ned is what i was called as a child but
you can't call me ned not when you've
just started to call me edwin ned would
be too intimate don't you think
and we do best you and i on modest
rations of intimacy we're actors
places his right foot on the fender do
you ever wish you were a child again
marina ah you don't either something we
have in common although i suspect we
haven't much in common you and i besides
being actors
granted that is a great deal
is it not marina
do i have your complete attention marina
i see your gaze wandering in
embarrassment let's say to the bust of
shakespeare on top of the bookcase stare
away
you'll find a picture or a bust of
shakespeare in every room here
shall i get it down for you
walks to the bookcase
no
you see you'd rather stare at me
pat's shakespeare on the head
acting marina is what you and i do
we played together before an audience
this evening
tolerably well i might add
and sans audience we shall go on acting
with each other yes but of course we
shall be perfectly perfectly sincere
makes a stage bow
whom shall i play i think let me see
i think i shall impersonate
edwin booth
what an outstanding idea he seems a much
more interesting fellow than [ __ ] and
every bit as unhappy famously unhappy
brooding wonderfully equipped to play
tragic roles
however don't think me too tyrannical
i'd prefer tonight that you not play
marina
fetches a bottle of whiskey from a
cabinet
could you consider it
just to humor me surely you have a few
other selves in your repertory i do
think it very entertaining that for the
last 10 years everyone has agreed that
the greatest actress in the
english-speaking world
is a pole
a pole
with an accent
yes marina
no one mentions your accent anymore it's
part of your magic but it is very very
noticeable
ah for god's sake don't pout woman
i shall not deny that accent and all you
phrase better than most who own the
language
another glass good
i'm curious to see when it will have an
effect on you
circle sir
you are enchanting marina zalenska
either i'm being quite sincere
or i just want to flatter you
which do you think
or neither
maybe i'm a parrot
squawks like a parrot don't be alarmed
my father sometimes did that
in the wings
simpering and screeching and squawking
just before he went on and became
instantly noble
eloquent
melodious
what was i saying oh yes they were
saying the most enchanting person i ever
met doesn't that ever trouble you marina
do you never ask yourself what in god's
name must i have done to myself that
people should find me so enchanting
kisses her hand
you probably know that i had no success
playing romeo and soon dropped it from
my repertory
as for benedict i was never a good
benedict i could never be light enough
there is something earth bound in me
i shall never fly out of it
oh well
we must do what we do best
don't you agree
i like playing villains best
pity we're not doing richard iii on the
tour
twists his body becomes misshapen that
was father's first great role
and you've been lady anne though not yet
with me alas who cannot resist dick
crook back when he plays the lover
straightens up
tell me are you that much younger than i
don't blush woman do you think we're on
a stage here well
your secret shall be safe with me
i see you hesitating
i see you want to please me
i thought so
well you're still my junior by seven
years
and quite good looking capital for a
woman
am i being too sardonic
are you in need of some bomb
all actors need to be flattered
who would know this better than edwin
booth let's see what can i say to please
you that would also be true
ah yes
points his finger at her
you walk well
i liked your walk tonight
you don't forget the play is set in
venice
porsche walks as if she is treading on
marble
i shall remember that
that means i shall steal it
from now on [ __ ] too shall walk on
marble
walks across the room walk becomes
mincing stops laughs
you see i am still working on the role
after all these years
my father would when he had a run of
shylocks to do
go about muttering in hebrew
or something that sounded like hebrew
once while doing [ __ ] in atlanta he
went into that city's finest restaurant
and ordered ham and greens
and when the waiter brought it to his
table
dashed the plate to the floor shrieking
unclean
unclean [ __ ] and stormed out of the
restaurant
i of course swim the very soul of
rationality don't for a minute think as
[ __ ] when i'm not on stage
in the jews dark brown gabardine and
tawny yellow slouch hat holding the
knotted walking stiff staff in my
be-ringed right hand
stretches out his hand to her
nor do i think as othello except when i
have made myself [ __ ] as the more or
even as richard third
much as i relish the role
hamlet
perhaps
you could say i have a weakness for
hamlet not because everyone thinks i am
hamlet like i hamlet like as my father
would say f
still hamlet
reminds me of something in myself
maybe it's that hamlet
is an actor
yes marina that's all he is he is acting
he seems to be one thing and underneath
that seeming what is there
nothing
nothing
nothing
the inky black suit he wears at court in
the second scene
that tenacious
showy mourning for his father
everyone's father dies as gertrude
reminds him and right she is
why seems it's so particular with thee
and hamlet howls his howling you know
seems madam nay it is i know not seems
but he does know seems he knows nothing
else that's his problem hamlet would
give anything anything not to be an
actor
but he is condemned to it
condemned to being an actor
he is waiting to break through seeming
and performing
and just
be
but there is nothing on the other side
of seeming marina
except death
except death
looks around the room
i'm looking for my yorick skull
could i have misplaced it
yorick
where are you
what did i do with that skull
pulls open the roll top desk tosses
papers on the floor a prop a prop
my kingdom for a prop
my last line would have gone so much
more resoundingly if i could have
brandished a skull
except death
except death
did you hear the capital d
on the second death
of such wee details are great
performances made but i'm sure you did
hear it marina what better audience than
you could a crushed tragedian have
stretches out her hand to her
my little princess my polish queen
you have kindly consented to keep ned
company as he sinks into his cups you
know he is quite harmless since he is so
drunk so your virtue is safe even if you
are a respectable married woman not so
young and so forth but beware of old ned
he's a sly one
does a pirouette he may only be
pretending to be drunk perhaps he really
is just deranged and therefore just a
little little dangerous
like hamlet he's a sly one too he
pretends not to be acting and he gives
acting lessons to others
speak the speech i pray you as i
pronounced it to you trippingly on the
tongue
don't you think his instructions to the
actors are rather obvious
very
suit the action to the word
the word to the action
why he's as banal as polonius
where's the fire where's the
recklessness
perhaps i should play hamlet on tiptoe
the whole play from start to finish as
my father once did lear in buffalo
or in a whisper as he once did iago in
philadelphia
of course my father was mad
or drunk or both
one couldn't easily tell which
like me is that what you're thinking
marina it isn't oh i thought you were
going to be sincere with your old friend
ned
sits beside her on the divine but is
hamlet mad much inc spilled over that i
should say that hamlet must be
considered mad because only a mad person
would think of disguising himself as a
mad person when there are so many other
disguises to choose from
but perhaps not
perhaps there aren't many disguises to
choose from suppose being mad is the
only one available what do you think
marina in which case hamlet's choice
makes perfect sense a most excellent
rational charming prince of denmark i
always say a tad unhappy to be sure
very unhappy indeed but if to be happy
excuse me but if to be unhappy were to
be mad
why then
we would all be mad
takes off his shoes and rubs his feet
am i boring you i hope not because now
i'm coming to your role jumps up
ophelia goes mad so it's not interesting
raving about flowers hamlet wasn't nice
to her poor girl hamlet stuck his blade
into his her father's gut
and his mother was getting on his nerves
and he thought there was a rat behind
the curtain
picks up the poker from the fireplace
brandishes it like a sword
and off she went into the water
do you understand about madness marina i
don't think so
idly odds that you are very expert at
fending off your griefs
not all together of course am i right a
little little bit of suffering
are you europeans you invented tragedy
so you think you have a monopoly on it
and we americans we are all callow
optimists
right
i can feel an excess of calor optimism
coming on right now
how refreshing
another whiskey marina you know the only
time i've seen you make a feel you
really seem mad was last week in
providence when unusually for you
distracted could it have been by me
gnashing my teeth alongside you in the
wings you made your entrance in act four
empty-handed
and entirely unflustered
proceeded to distribute your invisible
posey to gertrude and claudius and
laertes
father would have liked that
pours himself a drink
did i say my father squawked like a
parrot
i remember a hamlet in natchez when
during ophelia's mad scene
a voice off stage began to crow like a
rooster
and sure enough it was father perched on
top of a high ladder in the wings
crows
like that
so dear ophelia
do look about you when going mad it can
be contagious
my mother worried so about father when
he was on the road
that at 14 she set me out with him to be
his dresser and companion not to learn
acting anything but that johnny was to
be the actor
the heir
father said i ought to be a cabinet
maker so it was a great
sign
when he invited me to eat shakespeare
with him one night in waterbury
bitter i thought delicious he said some
pages from lear
well hamlet we were talking about hamlet
was a prince who expected rightly
expected to be the air
returns to the fireplace
don't you think hamlet's father
is the mad one
it seems to me quite mad to turn
yourself into a ghost and come back to
haunt your son
but at least hamlet didn't have a
brother
who could come back and haunt him
you know after johnny fired the shot
he leaped from the presidential box onto
the stage and shouted his line sick
semper you know
and broke his leg
limps over to the desk
i'm about to have another drink marina
yes
one sign of an approaching paroxysm of
my father's appetite for liquor
was his use of a peculiar gesture like
this
the air with his right hand beside his
head
and if i would try to stop him from
drinking which was part of my job he
would make that ominous gesture and
shout go away young man go away by god
sir i'll put you aboard a man of war sir
sheer nonsense as you see nothing could
be done to stop him only undress him
after and clean up his vomit
lifts his glass
to you
old mole
he was a great actor
you must take my word for it marina
truly great
he had astounded london as richard iii
when he was 21
and was hailed as the rival and
successor to keane
and he made his new york debut a few
years later in the same role my father
as the hunchbacked villain was part of
my life from early childhood on he would
enter the stage from the left amidst a
tempest of boisterous
a boisterous hand clapping
the first thing one saw was his lifted
foot passing the wing then
the rest of him followed head bent
he slowly walked down the stage to the
footlights musingly
kicking his sword
which he held by its sash
away from his body
forty years have passed and i can hear
the clank of the sword
and feel the eerie hush of 3 000 people
waiting for him to open his mouth now
is the winter of our discontent
i suppose
father's style of acting was inflated
and stagey
certainly would be considered so by
today's standards nobody called him
introspective and intellectual as they
do me
laughs
he obeyed his terrors
he recognized
the devil in himself
father had sworn never to eat meat
dead flesh he called it and once when he
broke his rule
did penance by filling his shoes with
dried peas
then fitting them with lead souls
and trudging all the way from baltimore
to washington
he thought he was bad
he knew some of the time
he was mad i can't read i'm a charity
boy i can't read take me to the lunatic
asylum he once shouted in the middle of
a lear at the wheating in syracuse he
was hustled off stage to the sound of
more than a few catcalls but such
outbursts on stage were rare oh
what do i see i'm still in my stocking
feet
puts his shoes back on
i gabble on
about my father
because it hurts so to talk about my
brother
when i talk about johnny
i weep
raises his hand imperiously not yet wait
to kill a king
that's a great deed johnny would to
claim you'll see soon the name of booth
will be known everywhere i thought it
was johnny posturing how can an actor be
taken seriously it's all hokum vanity
boasting an actor is always trying to
make himself interesting first he has to
make himself interesting to himself then
to other people do you find yourself
interesting marina
looks about for his glass
threats augurs
and we hear only what we want to hear
did lincoln's wife
heed him
when the great emancipator told her the
dream he'd had in which he was
drifting down alone
a dark river
no
they went to the theater
laughs
johnny was already much admired who
knows if he would not have been more
successful than i even than father if he
had not if he had lived
he was wonderful in romantic roles
marina romeo the lot not for him the
villains richard iii and iago and the
scottish lord are the great
self-deceivers like hamlet and othello
he received hundreds of letters a week
from lovesick women and girls not to
mention the missives from the women
lucky enough to be granted his favors
begins to cry
johnny wanted to be loved
takes out an embroidered handkerchief
if i weep now
will you think these are actors tears
they are you know
hath not an actor eyes
if you prick him dothy not bleed
i was playing at the boston theater when
it happened
it was thought at first
to be a family conspiracy and junius my
older brother was arrested though soon
let go i wasn't arrested
but my movements were watched by the
police
all the booths received death threats
gazes at his hands
on politics johnny and i quarreled like
demons since i was for the union an
abolition i'd voted twice for lincoln
johnny thought he had killed a tyrant
he expected to be acclaimed as a hero
his death was excruciating
and the booths will always be
his family
thank you
[Applause]
oh
do we have questions
yes
will you please stand up so that more
people can hear well i'll repeat the
question don't worry yeah
in your reading in preparation for the
novel did you run across any accounts of
edwin booth ever having spoken about his
brother after the assassination
no no it's all made up
but there is this there are two very
touching i did read a biography of both
the standard biography that's called the
prince of players i think it's an old
biography from 40 years ago or something
and they were just too um no on the
contrary he wouldn't talk about him
um
there are uh
just two things that touched me very
much one is that he did keep all his
life a picture of his brother
uh on the wall next to uh his bed
a little photograph and the other was
that he saved he kept everything of his
brothers the costumes the letters the
everything and then about five years
after his death he um went down to the
basement of the theater
where he kept these things his own
theater there was a theater in he he
tried to be a businessman very
unsuccessfully edwin both in the act she
had a theater in new york called booth
theater which was supposed to be a
temple of dramatic art in the european
model it didn't last very long
but anyway he had he the middle of the
night two in the morning he took a stage
hand down
with him and he he just says very
laconically in a letter and i burned
everything of johnny's without opening
without looking at it and some of them
were even costumes of fathers because of
course as you as you understand from the
story uh i mean the facts are right
booth came from
an acting father a very very famous and
quite mad uh acting father and he was
indeed sent out by the mother to sort of
be the father's minder
when he was a child and and so he spent
his whole adolescence with this crazy
father who died when he was uh 19. he
edwin booth was 19. anyway you know uh i
want to respond to something else
because the question was did i ever come
across anything how much of the words
all the words are made up they're all i
mean just as
my
marina zelenska is
well yes she has some of the same
actions in the larger external sense as
the polish actress helena majesca but
it's a completely new character and the
psychology and
the motivations and the relationships
are all completely uh invented
but the question was
in my reading in preparation
for the novel did i whatever find
something about booth
where he says something about his
brother so i just wanted to share with
you a little a little trick if it is a
trick or a strategy i don't i didn't
either for the volcano lover or this
book read in preparation at all
if i ever read in preparation i would
never start it i would have been so
overwhelmed by how much i didn't know
and how much more i wanted to know
before i felt empowered or authorized to
begin the book that never would have
begun the book so the way
maybe it's why i begin with prologues
um
which are a sort of strange way both in
the in the i never thought of it until
this minute uh maybe i'm just kind of uh
sort of winding up a little bit further
behind the plate and
giving myself a little time so i'm
actually in the book
uh so i know i've really started it and
i really got something down but i don't
yet have to really have the
um
you know i'm not really
so bound to the whole question of the
the historical
um
substance that i need to have in my head
the material what i keep calling the
material world that i have to have very
clearly and vividly and visually in my
head
um
so the reading is done as i write and
there's a lot of reading after finish
uh to check everything and when i find
i've made some ridiculous mistakes and
then i fix them i don't read before i
just plunge in
however however there's a very funny
thing in in this book it starts as i
said with an uh with a monologue as it
ends with this booth monologue i just
read you the first little bit of it
um in which
a kind of author voice a sort of me uh
um
was not really me because i think i
would have some different somewhat
different reactions than this voice has
but anyway
somebody from the end of the 20th
century
like a time traveler
parachutes back into
a situation um
and figures out it it turns out that it
is a
dinner party a private dinner party in a
private dining room of a hotel
in the winter and it's actually december
1875 and the second floor of a
uh hotel in krakow in western poland in
southwestern poland
and the way i constructed this
and and so already i was a bang up
against my utter ignorance of of the
period uh and of course i don't read
polish i have good polish friends
including two here in the front row but
i don't know paul any polish obviously
and uh
and every polish literature and film i
obviously know in translation and by
subtitles
so i had everything to learn anyway i
have the the first line of the book
well actually
why why get it wrong i can read it to
you and i can read it to you it starts
irresolute
no shivering
i'd crashed a party in the private
dining room of a hotel
it felt wintry indoors too but none of
the women and gowns and men in frock
coats churning about the long dark hued
room
seemed to mind the chill so i had the
tile stove in a corner all to myself
that's the first sentence of the book
well i
uh had this person who crashed
this invisible time traveler crashes the
party
um
uh standing not in front of a
tile stove but in front of a fireplace
because seemed you know i decided it was
winter and a couple of seconds later
that
that invisible presence is going to go
to a window and look down on
on on sleds and coachmen and horses
waiting patiently outside for these
rather distinguished people who are at
the party
but i had this person
you know talking about a room heated by
fireplace so there i was right up
against it this is the kind of thing how
you can go wrong all the time
the fact is the rooms weren't by and
large heated by fireplaces
in poland
any more than they were heated by
fireplaces in northern germany or in
sweden
i should have actually known this
because i lived in sweden for two years
and
the normal way in which any older house
or apartment is heated is by a very
large beautiful tile stove
then of course very modern buildings
have the normal kind of you know
electric heating or whatever
uh and the same is true in poland you
could go quite a way before you found a
fireplace in a house or a hotel in in
poland so but i had a fireplace i had a
fireplace and uh
and then when i made my first trip to
poland to kind of look around and kind
of see what i could see or feel or or
pick up in the way of some
little details not that any bunch of
anything except the historic center of
krakow looks the way it did then uh i
asked all my friends now do you know any
house or a
public place that has a fireplace and
they said no no
they all have tile big style stoves so
reluctantly because i'd so imagined
this character this invisible character
warming her hands you know be in front
of a fire i uh
i said okay it's a tile stove and that's
the first set so i could even i i got it
wrong right away and i had to fix it up
but then i also thought well
i know i'm gonna end up with booth back
in his rooms in this actress club to
which he's invited my character you know
15 years later
uh they've you know they've performed
together and he said uh come back with
me and
you know it's not exactly the thing you
do of a married woman going back to a
dance apartment in those days but you
know she's she's an independent
character
uh even though they're not lovers and
she has no one she adores him but it's
not that kind of relationship she does
go back with him and she knows he is the
unhappiest man in the world
uh
and uh i thought boy i'm gonna end with
booth and he's gonna have a fireplace
and you heard he keeps walking over to
that fireflies walking around that's
because i couldn't get the fireplace in
the in the prologue so i had to put it
in at the end uh
anything else yes
is there a particular piece of music
toward which you are working toward
being able to play and do you span an
octave
well this refers to
the question is is there a particular
piece of music i'm playing and do i span
an octave
this is because it was revealed in a
rather
impertinent and partly inaccurate new
yorker profile of me
but at the advanced age of 67 i've
started to take piano lessons which i've
always wanted to do
and yes i do span an octave and i am of
course starting with bach what else
would one start with and i can play
little toy bach things you know bach
wrote these wonderful little things for
his wife
um
and that's what i have started with but
i also do an enormous amount of
of um
i've only been doing a couple of months
two months so it's not i mean i'm you
know where a four-year-old would be
uh and it's kind of interesting doing
what a four-year-old can
learns to do or a six-year-old learns to
do it trying to do it when you're 67.
i have two enormous advantages over a
four-year-old or a six-year-old one is i
have a lifetime of listening to
classical music and i understand a lot
about classical music and i know a lot
about classical music
so i love i love the idea of finally
learning to play a musical instrument so
i can listen better that's the point of
it of course
um the second thing is i'm the kind of
person who's never bored
and i it's my understanding the children
are easily bored when they're set to
learning a musical instrument
my disadvantage and also i'm lucky
i've got all my marbles i don't have any
memory problems um
but
my i have one interesting disadvantage
um
which is that i have a hard time you
talk about octave that's not the problem
the hard
thing i
have a hard time doing which i do think
is a function of my age
is i have a hard time making my left
hand do one thing in my right hand do
something else and i'm sure that's
because my neurological pathways are
kind of very solidly
um used and that children small children
and that's really that's why it is a
good thing for small children uh to
start small children learning an
instrument
i think small children are
easily
ambidextrous or partly ambidextrous and
that that compa that
that
sort of natural ambidextrousness
uh fades
with with just having a life not not
with age as such but just a number of
years in which you're used to one hand
doing one thing and another hand doing
something else where a child of four or
six or seven or whenever children start
to learn to play the piano or the violin
anything hasn't got all those years of
specialized use of the hands so
i have uh i've gotten myself hannan if
you know what that is those of you and
uh you know i'm trying to teach my left
hand to do one thing in my right hand to
do something else and i'm having a
ball
uh
so i encourage everybody to take up a
musical instrument or retake of a
musical instrument it's really one of
the great pleasures and i'm
there's no other reason to do it it's
real pleasure and are you aspiring
toward a particular piece in the future
well of course i want to be able to play
schubert you know of course i want i
mean who doesn't i'd love to play
beethoven and schubert and so on but
that'll be a long that'll be a long time
away of course i want to play just what
everybody wants to play who loves music
i want to play bach and mozart and
scarletty
and handel and and beethoven and
schubert and brahms and you know you
know that stuff stuff
that stuff that stuff too i think it's
like dying and going to heaven to be
able to play these things for yourself
and really be able to hear them
properly i'm an evangelist as you say so
i mean i'm just an incorrigible
evangelist
uh
yes
as you were talking about um the booths
booth brothers i remember a piece you
wrote a long time ago about uh dr jekyll
mr hyde
and i wondered if that was in your mind
at all as you were talking about the
booth brothers that's great no i wasn't
at all that was a story called called um
called dr jekyll
no it wasn't
how interesting
listen i want to tell you something my
idea this is this is how american i am
my idea is um it's always a fresh start
i'm always you know striking out for the
horizon the frontier remaking myself
transforming myself now i've really got
it now i'm going to become a good writer
now it's this is like anything i ever
did before and it's really going to be
good and
you know
we
this is our sort of central
mythology uh that and the love of money
but we'll forget about that
uh
our central mythology is this very
beautiful idea of
self-transformation and self-improvement
and
and
and making things new and
starting again and all that and in fact
i suppose that's why i love these the
the confluence of these two stories of
the immigrant story
and the actor story because you could
say immigrants
immigrants from the old world to the new
world
especially this kind of immigrant that
these people were educated people
conscious people people who read
tockville you know people weren't coming
in steerage overwhelmed by you know and
totally intimidated by america but
people had
cultivated europeans who were
giving up everything
and
but opening themselves to an absolutely
new experience but still a lot of stuff
going on in their head
um that's a story of people wanting to
to transform to be transformed hoping to
be transformed marina my you know my
version of the polish actress story i
mean which i just use as a trampoline to
you know make my own story
um
she's
precisely in search of
self-transformation
and she thinks it's going to happen by
giving up being an actor but of course
an actor is a specialist in
self-transformation so the two things
come together
uh
so
it's interesting when you mention
something of mine that i wrote a long
time ago a story called dr jekyll that
yeah i i
obviously work out of some basic um
you know
a set of passions or
fantasies or obsessions
and they must reoccur
but i have to say that if i ever thought
that i was repeating myself that would
be a very strong reason not to do what i
was doing
i mean i have to have that
sense that it's quite new and that i'm
not
i'm doing something like nothing i ever
did before
oh just one or two more questions yes
it seems to me when we write about the
past that we don't really write the past
but we kind of sent out a mirror at a
certain part of history a certain point
in the past and we kind of see how our
ideas look
at that point reflected back at us
at least you know i think that's very
true i think it's very true i'd like to
to
to a certainly for fiction writer i
think it's a very uh
subtle and accurate way of putting it
we're not a fiction writer i'm not a
historian though i mean i had to learn a
lot like somebody you know taking a
history course in the 1870s and 1880s i
had to learn a lot but i'm not
functioning as as a historian i'm
functioning as an imaginative
uh writer as a writer of fiction and i
think that the
one wants to tell this story for the way
it functions as a mirror i think that's
a very uh very good image but of course
once again i
the task of getting it right while it's
a very small part ultimately of what
makes this i think a really good book
very very small part is still crucial
i didn't know for instance i guess i
didn't know anything uh i mean i didn't
know that there was a great depression
that started in 1873. uh every bit is
severe if not more so is the one that
happened in 1929.
it was called a panic it wasn't called a
crash it was at the panic of 73. it's a
huge huge event
the country was devastated uh uh and in
incredible economic trouble and vast
immigration went on for years and years
uh really didn't get back on track until
the 1880s
uh when i sort of decided to follow the
very external frame of of of of the real
story and and you know they really did
come in 1876 so first i thought oh who
needs that i'll put it in the in the
1890s that's more interesting because if
i knew anything much more about and that
than i did about the but i don't know i
was a little scared i thought it's 1890s
that must be more interesting uh but
then i said why not it what does it
matter i'm still going to have to work
it up uh to some degree and then i
started
saying okay 1876 it's three years after
the start of a depression which of
course they don't know anything about
and they one of the reasons the farm
fails when i say it's not simple
is because of the the prices of grapes
have gone flat
what much much less than it was a couple
years earlier it doesn't i mean it's not
their fault they were they did a lot of
work but uh they walked into a really
difficult economic situation
um and so on and so on that's not the
only reason but uh
um
it's true the you i i said
i chose this story i invented this story
because with this story
there were a number of stories i could
tell and there's there there's a kind of
shahrazad
aspect to the book there's a lot of
stories within the book where people
will actually even say let me tell you
my story and then we'll come three four
five pages of somebody else's story a
new character completely new character
um but it it
the interest is
that it is mirror to the present and you
look at it with the concerns of the past
while remain excuse me you look at it
with the concerns of the present how
could you not
um
and
there's a kind of dialogue between the
what you bring to this story and what
you draw out of this story
uh this novel is is a novel that takes
place in the 19th century but in no
sense is it a 19th century novel it's a
novel that could not have been written
anytime but
in the late
well late 1990s
thank you very much
[Applause]